Shh I’m accessing my mind palace like Sherlock
Holmes…huh… living room is a bit smaller
than I expected… bedroom's kinda cramped…
But LOTS of storage!
I actually STORE in there?
Hey there my neuro-nerds, Trace here for DNews.
Now we all know that our brains can store
an incredible amount of information -- a lifetime
of memories, everything from the good, the
bad and the downright embarrassing.
Up until recently, it was thought that the
brain could only hold the equivalent of 100
terabytes of information, max -- which, let's
face it, is a lot.
But it turns out our brains may actually have
ten times that capacity.
In a 2016 study conducted by The Salk Institute,
researchers discovered our brains could store
at least a petabyte of information!
A petabyte is the equivalent of approximately
one thousand terabytes or one million gigabytes!
To put it another way, if you were to continuously
play a petabyte of 4-minute songs, it would
take 2,000 years to listen to all of them.
To-do list, check.
Obviously, this unit of measurement is generally
used for computer memory not brain capacity,
but neuroscientists can also use bytes as
a useful comparison for our brain's own storage
capacity.
So, both elephants and whales have physically
larger brains, but relatively speaking, our
body-to-brain ratio is about the same as a
mouse!
Learning about how our brains store and process
information can give us insight into why we
seem to be more intelligent than other animals.
When you experience something, let's say,
your first kiss, that experience is converted
into pulses of electrical energy coming from
your external senses (lips, nose, hands, for
example) and your internal senses (emotional
responses and heart rate).
That electrical energy is fired across the
brain through a network of neurons until it
reaches the hippocampus -- a sort of memory
data bank, though some recent studies suggest
that certain long-term memories might also
be stored in the Cerebral cortex.
Everything we do produces pulses, thousands
of them every day, and each one travels across
neurons via specific gap called a synapse.
In that synaptic junction, neurotransmitter
chemicals ferry the pulses from one neuron
to the next as fast as possible.
The brain has roughly 86 billion neurons,
not 100 billion, only 86.
Specifically.
Myth busteeedddd!!
And each brain cell connects to at least one
other, but likely more!
Meaning there are TRILLIONS of synapses.
The gap between the neurons is small, only
20 to 40 nanometers, but studies seem to indicate
these synapses are crucial in the process
of making and storing memories.
To find out how, the Salk Institute used a
3D digital model of a rat’s hippocampus,
and examined how synapse size effects brain
capacity and efficiency, and in doing so,
noticed something unusual… in 10 percent
of cases a single neuron had two synapses
connected to the same neighboring neuron…
They were sending two copies of the exact
same message!
Curiously, those two synapses varied in size
by 8 percent, and when it comes to synapses,
size really DOES matter.
Larger synaptic gaps require more neurotransmitter
chemicals so they're more likely to succeed
in communicating their electrical data to
the neighbouring neuron.
That simple eight percent variation enabled
researchers to create mathematical models,
concluding that synapses come in 26 different
discrete sizes!
Exiting RIGHT?!
Trust me, it is.
This size variation is almost ten times what
was previously thought.
Suggesting that more size variability means,
in digital terms, synapses are able to process
4.7 bits of memory.
Previously scientists thought synapses could
only process one or two bits…
A small change, but, again, given there are
trillions of synapses spread throughout the
brain, the researchers calculated one petabyte
capacity.
Now, before we get too excited, remember,
this study wasn’t modeled on a human brain…
but a rat brain, although scientists think
it could translate to humans.
And some neuroscientists believe the estimation
is low!
Maybe we could store 2-3 petabytes of memory!
It’s a lot to think about…!
Pun intended.
We know you love watching online, but DNews
is also on Science channel!
Amy and I share a minute of the best in science
in between awesome programming.
So check out as Science Presents DNews at
9!
Every weeknight, Monday through Friday, and
use your twitter to let them know if you want
more!